good morning welcome back fed up parents
in new york city taking legal action to
get their kids back in the classroom
full time
they say students are suffering under
the current hybrid system
and begging to be back in school new
york city mom
natalia morocco is leading the charge
and she joins us now natalia good to see
you thank you for being here
thank you for having me okay so i know
that it's been a whirlwind i know that
there's been
back and forths and i know that you
among many others are completely
frustrated
kids are set to return to school in new
york city on april 26th
however i know an update last night some
parents are receiving emails from their
schools telling them that the department
of education is putting this three-foot
rule on hold
so do you know does this put this april
26
date in jeopardy now so
um this is april 26th is the day
when uh newly opted in about 51 000
students
who had previously been fully remote the
newly opted-in students who
who have now opted into full-time
learning are set to return
that's still holding however schools
elementary schools in particular
had sent out emails to parents this week
telling them
that they've adopted the three-foot rule
in the classroom and that all
kids in most schools not all
schools would be going time at the same
time as the new kids
from remote would return on april 26th
last night
we got a flurry of texts emails
calls from parents who are panicking
because their schools have sent them
emails saying
this the three foot rule is on hold no
one's coming back full time
we'll keep you updated but there's been
a whole hold up with the union
that's that's the rumor i haven't gotten
confirmation
i imagine as a parent you just put your
head down and you just kind of cry
sometimes when you get these texts or
these emails and you see this because
you feel for your kids too who have been
struggling this entire last year is that
in part
what made you to become such a force to
be able to put your foot down and say
you know i need to really fight legally
yes because we're just not seeing any
advocacy for the children
on the part of you know the doe and
the city they're really failing our
children um
we're we're hoping that they're seeing
that
the urgency children need to be back in
school this
you know crazy schedule this up and down
you know the two case rule that was
around up until just a few weeks
ago that would shut down schools for 10
days with no scientific basis
repeatedly i mean schools which get shut
down four or five times that's 50 days
since september we just don't know what
to expect
and we can't rely the mayor to to look
to science
for you know for guidance on how to
bring all kids
back to school full-time you have two
kids that are young
i believe they are 7 and 10. what are
the differences you've seen in them
in the last year oh
i mean just not having the consistency
of a schedule
has been so disruptive it's hard to get
them to go to sleep at night it's hard
to get them to
to wake up in the morning my
seven-year-old
cries and she's so sad she doesn't
understand why there are all these days
where she can't see her teacher her
class
or her friends the socialization has
been impeded
in a big way uh you know the cohorts
that they're in are so
tiny that there just aren't that many
kids you know in the class to begin with
and many of the kids
who they know you know go on alternate
days
so it's just it's a very strange
environment it's it's
i'm not going to call it the new normal
because we don't accept this
we want them all back full time every
day
from pre-k to 12th grade i mean we're
also not talking about middle or
elementary school
excuse me middle or high school middle
and high school
are are not coming back full time and
there's no current plan to adopt the
three feet
for them so we're we're completely
missing those kids and
they're all very vulnerable too natalia
marquer thank you for joining us
um keep us updated on how everything
goes okay thank you i will thank you
ashley